okay
this is hilarious because you always
have these um
women that are always like i'm so strong
and independent and
single moms are the best blah blah blah
but check this out
she has a complete meltdown here in her
car let me play this
tick-tock hey of all places i've just
been yelling in my car for 30 minutes
because
[ __ ] parenting is hard
it's hard
yeah no god they're little mirrors
if if i want my son
to be a better person or to grow up
and just be a good [ __ ] human
i have to be a good person
he mirrors everything so if i have a
[ __ ] bad attitude he's going to have
a goddamn bird attitude
if i say [ __ ] of course he's going to
say [ __ ]
they have to change me to change you
oh man so she's she's complaining
because she can't behave like a brat
because she's realizing that when she
does
her kid mimics her behaviors and she has
she's
it's almost like she's looking in a
mirror when she's dealing with her kid
and she doesn't like
the kid and she realized well she
doesn't like the kid because she doesn't
like herself
but um i don't know man i
you know i talk about this stuff all the
time and most guys don't listen half the
time they just move
right past it they just ignore all the
advice and
who cares she looks pretty i'm gonna
take her home whatever
but this is why you stay away from these
single moms man they raise these
you know these nightmares and they think
they can do it all on their own and the
father's never around
they either push him out of the kid's
life or the the guy bounces or whatever
happens happens i don't know but it's
just
it's just a disaster
you